so this situation in waukesha wisconsin
continues to to
percolate
we still do not know why the the person
the the 39 year old black male who
decided to drive a a car into a crowd of
children why he did that we don't know
and we probably will never find out
because we are not allowed to ask such
questions because to ask such questions
might reveal that certain ideologies are
are not in fact good
according to the us son the suspect in
the christmas parade rampage that killed
five revelers wrote an anti-donald trump
rap and declared f the pigs according to
songs posted online
one of his songs includes the lyrics
they're gonna need a cleaner for the
bleep we did all my killers at gacy
where their bodies hid here's a little
bit of his uh of his brilliant rap
[Music]
so um both untalented incoherents and
has a terrible philosophy well we're not
supposed to investigate any of that
though if andy no posts anything about
his philosophy the journalists among us
what will shield us from the from the
vicious reality that maybe this guy
believed a lot of really bad stuff
by the way you know that if this has
been a white guy who drove a car into a
crowd filled with children and they had
found on his facebook page a bunch of
white supremacist garbage that would
immediately be the leading
motive that was suspected we know this
for a fact
so again blinding ourselves to reality
okay so this brings us to the most
obvious issue with what is happening in
in waukesha so one thing that we clearly
know at this point that this person
should have been in prison and there's
no question that this guy should have
been in jail at this point
we know that he was out on bail thousand
dollars bail
from apparently using his car to hit
somebody like a few days before
and then he was just set free
joe biden finally reacted to waukesha by
the way uh it took him
like 48 hours to react to waukesha uh
suffice to say that if the races had
been reversed it would take him less
than a second and a half right if you're
a black guy if he'd been a white guy
driving a car into a crowd of blackheads
biden would've been to the microphone
before
the car had stopped moving um but this
was a black guy using a car to hit a
bunch of white kids and so apparently
that is um that's a different thing you
got you got it you can be considered
about it by the way should be considered
in both situations here is here's uh joe
biden finally sounding off about
waukesha
we know this morning
that five
families in waukesha
are facing fresh grief
of a life without a loved one
at least 40 americans are suffering from
injuries
some of them in critical condition
and an entire community is struggling
struggling to cope with the horrific act
of violence
last night the people of waukesha
were gathered to celebrate the start of
a season of hope and togetherness and
thanksgiving
this morning
jill and i and the entire biden family
and i'm sure all of us pray
that that same spirit is going to
embrace and lift up all the victims of
this tragedy
okay so glad that joe biden could be
bothered to emerge and say these things
uh it is uh it is also true that we know
at least from a policy perspective why
this happened according to cbs 58 in
wisconsin the waukesha police department
is referring five counts of intentional
homicide for the man accused of ramming
his suv into the waukesha christmas
parade those charges carry possible life
sentences there's the possibility more
charges will be filed as the
investigation progressives
this was not the first time that this
suspect and again i don't use names for
people who do this sort of stuff because
i don't like people being glorified for
this i don't think they should become
famous because of this i think that they
should be thrown in jail to rot and then
forgotten because that's what they
deserve this is not the first time this
suspect allegedly ran someone over with
his car
just three weeks ago he ran over a woman
he had a child with
but at the time his bail was set at just
a thousand dollars he paid it and was
released
now the milwaukee county district
attorney's office is conducting an
internal review into why the bail was
set inappropriately low
justice janine ngiski who is on the
wisconsin supreme court from 93 to 98
explain quote there are hundreds and
hundreds of cases in milwaukee county
even the backlog of full homicides is
tremendous at this point
judge justice gusky said the district
attorney's office recommends the bail
amount to a court commissioner before
it's approved by a judge
it's not unusual for a court
commissioner to be sending 30 40 50
cases of bail on a day
the bail amount is supposed to consider
a person's prior record character
whether they might flee or they might
commit a crime while out on bail
but there are plenty of red flags
because um this guy had a bail jumping
felony he had second degree recklessly
endangering safety felonies
he paid the 1 000 bail he was released
november 11th 10 days before the
waukesha parade the da's office now says
in a statement quote the bail
recommendation in this case is not
consistent with the approach of the
milwaukee county district attorney's
office toward matters involving violent
crime nor was it consistent with the
risk assessment of the defendant prior
to the setting of bail well there's only
one problem it's very consistent with
the with the milwaukee county d.a john
chisholm's approach
yesterday we talked to length on the
show about the fact that chisholm was
made nationally famous for his approach
to low bail
he put out a statement saying quote the
state's bail recommendation in this case
was inappropriate inappropriately low
and they're conducting an internal
review yeah no no bleeper conducting an
internal review
insane i mean it's totally crazy
okay but again we are now going to
obscure the real fact here we're going
to pretend that it was an suv right the
suv was the problem it's funny how this
works by the way if it's white guy an
suv runs down blackheads it's white guy
an suv runs down blackheads if it is in
fact a black guy in an suv running down
white kids then the suv is the problem
look at the way that the media report
these headlines right there there's a
headline today
from cnn breaking news quote five people
have died and more than 40 are injured
after an suv plowed through a holiday
parade in waukesha
well you know that's unfortunate when
the suv's just sort of run out of
control all by themselves this way
meanwhile the left continues to foment
the exact same garbage policy that led
to this in the first place
so alexander ocasio-cortez
literally put out a a message
to legislators today asking for bail
reform
she put out a tweet this is sent out
within 24 hours of waukesha quote today
we sent a letter with representative
carolyn maloney
chairman chairwoman of the committee on
oversight and reform and representative
jamie raskin two new york city's five
district attorneys requesting
information on excessive bail in the new
york city court system when prosecutors
seek excessive cash bail it results in
increased rates of incarceration
particularly for low-income defense well
we wouldn't want
we wouldn't want criminals in the
prisons we need them out on the streets
obviously
you know the level of blindness and
honestly self-confidence you have to
have to make a statement like this in
the immediate aftermath of waukesha
so this criminal is out on bail
inappropriately low bail
and like within 24 hours
she and the rest of the democratic party
apparently are releasing a statement
calling for low bail
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video